[Music]
welcome to the data science hangout if
you're joining for the first time i'm
rachel and it's great to meet you
if this is your first hangout this is an
open space for the whole data science
community to connect and check out about
data science leadership
questions you're facing and what's going
on in the world of data science you all
have probably heard me say that a lot of
times now these sessions are recorded
and shared to youtube as well
also on the data science hangout site so
you can always go back and re-watch or
find helpful resources shared there too
we always want to create spaces where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone
so there's three ways that you can ask
questions today and jump in you can
raise your hand on the zoom chat so i
can call on you
you could put questions in the zoom chat
and feel free to just put a little star
next to your question if you want me to
read it out loud instead
but we also have a slido link that tyler
or hannah will share in just a moment in
the chat so you can ask questions
anonymous or both of you at the same
time
um you can ask questions anonymously too
if you don't want to be part of the
recording
but just love to reiterate we really
want to hear from everyone no matter
your level of experience or the area of
work too
but with all of that i'm so excited to
be joined by my co-host for today alice
walsh alice is ep of translational
research at pathos
and alice i'd love to just have you
maybe introduce yourself and a little
bit about the work that you do to get us
going
yeah absolutely and let me know if you
have any problems hearing me um i had a
yogurt related microphone incident
before this started so i'm like hoping
that everything's going to be good
yeah so thank you so much rachel for
having me as mentioned i'm alice i live
here outside of philadelphia where i
work in drug development
and i think there's probably been i
don't know i'd be curious to hear on
this call like how many people do pharma
or like
research related activities
because i it's an interesting area
because
pharma development has always been very
data rich right there's always been
biostats teams who are involved in like
analyzing clinical trials and all that
sort of stuff and what i do is i'm
involved much earlier in the process so
i've worked with everything from drug
discovery teams who do target
identification like what should we even
make a drug for all the way through to
drugs that are in registrational trials
like big phase through studies and we're
trying to understand
more around what are the patients that
are responding to drugs and benefiting
from drugs versus those patients who
aren't
so i would describe myself as
training in computational biology
so i have a couple degrees in
engineering bioengineering biological
engineering and i got into drug
development because
i was really interested in working in
patient data so i did a phd where we did
some really interesting projects where
at university of pennsylvania you could
work with like a neurosurgeon and get
access to like brain cancer samples
and i thought like oh this is so amazing
i can look at like 20 patients and then
i interviewed with people in the
pharmaceutical industry and they were
like oh we have like a thousand patients
i was like oh my god that's amazing i
want to do that i want to work with
patient data and i want to try to
understand
um
you know what does disease mean at a
molecular level and how could we use
that information to make smarter drugs
or to identify the patients that really
should take our drugs
so
i can say a little bit about where i've
worked and things i've worked at jansen
um i worked at bristol-myers squibb uh
so those are two of like the largest
pharmaceutical companies where i was
doing my biomarker type work leading
teams who are working on those different
aspects of drug development
and so then most recently now i work at
a startup company so it's like the
complete opposite of working at a giant
company where you have lots of like
infrastructure and i.t and things like
that so i moved over to uh oncology
therapeutic startup where i was employee
number two and so now we have like five
people we're going to 10 people um so
it's really exciting to be part of a
company where
we're starting from scratch
awesome what's been the biggest change
in moving from a big company to this
startup other than the infrastructure
and all that
i have a lot fewer meetings
i don't know i like i've talked to
people before about like oh what's it
like day to day like in a big company
and i'm like well
if you like having 13 meetings a day
it's fantastic
which i'm a people person i like talking
to people so i actually didn't really
mind having like
nine to five
here's a meeting here here's a meeting
there's a very dynamic environment
um but it is difficult if you really
need to like put your head down and do
some a lot of like critical thinking and
so i was doing all my thinking time in
my car you know like driving between the
office and the house and now i work from
home and
i don't have that time but i just have a
lot more non-meeting time to like
do some thinking strategizing come up
with crazy ideas all that sort of stuff
so that's the biggest difference fewer
meetings because
when there's only four people at a
company it's really hard to talk to them
all day
by definition the math doesn't work to
have like 13 meetings a day yeah
definitely
i was actually going to wait to ask this
question but because you just said a lot
of your thinking happened and driving to
work and now you've switched to remote
work i know something you are interested
in is optimizing remote work and remote
teams so
curious to just hear
a bit about your
your thoughts on that yeah or what
you're facing yeah i know i was thinking
about that a lot like this weekend i
went for a bike ride and i was having
all these like ideas when i probably
should have been like paying attention
to not getting hit by a car or something
um but yeah now i have like
all the good ideas come like on the
treadmill
on the bike in the shower
like
i don't have the car time and i guess
also i probably should have been doing
like a lot of thinking in the car when i
was supposed to be paying attention to
the road
um but yeah i would love to talk to
people about um
how they're
doing remote work well especially for
data teams right like
if i think about
the types of interactions that i'm
having like
you don't necessarily want to like
make a big slide deck to explain
something to a colleague or a co-worker
so like communicating effectively when
all you have is like
slack huddles and like zoom meetings and
all those sorts of things as a challenge
um before before i joined the startup i
was remote working as well to some
extent right so
thanks to the pandemic but even without
the pandemic i was on a team where i had
direct reports in boston new jersey
and san francisco so we were already
like a distributed
team and we were working with people in
spain so we were working across like a
i don't know how many hours time zone
which is like an interesting challenge
but i would love to hear how other
people are optimizing for that because
i just feel like there's
got to be a better way like people have
got to learn something in the last
two years of pandemic about how to do
remote work really really well
yeah i'd love to open it up to everyone
if you have thoughts or want to share
anything in the chat too
i can share about what i just posted
which is not about about the book rest
by um
by alex payne he
so
rust is if you haven't read it you
should totally go read it it's fantastic
it gives lots of different accounts of
different people lots of them are
scientists some of them are technology
people
um
and it's accounts kind of all throughout
history of famous scientists who
used their downtime to do
their background brain work right like
the walking around on campus or the
mountain climbing or the whatever that
they did was really essential to the
background brain processes that they
needed to have ideas and think and all
that stuff um i've been working remotely
since 2015 and i feel like
i was not very good at it for a long
time but
i had a director at one point who was
like i need you to like take 15-minute
walks during your day it's like build
them as hours they're billable hours
this is part of you working for this
client i need you to go take walks
um and that really helped like building
that into your schedule so that you have
the white space to let your brain do
background work
um is really important otherwise you
just sit there and
you're at your screen for longer than a
couple of hours and your brain stops
doing all that background process work
because you're forcing it to do
too much you know stuff that's in front
of your face
i love that
a really good recommendation i'm going
to check out this book
i see um ravana you also put some
thoughts into the chat too if you want
to jump in
sure um i would like to get any advice
on how we can work to make brainstorming
more um
work better virtually because it seems
like that is an area where people are so
excited to get
out of meetings when they're virtual
um if anyone has any ideas about how to
improve on that process that would be
great
i can say a couple things
um i'm sorry i just got in the chat too
someone said get a dog don't get a dog
cause i'm just looking at my dog whining
at me from like
outside in the other room they're not
good um
the yeah the brainstorming thing is the
one that i've been trying out a couple
things like there are online platforms
like mural and probably like i've used a
couple other ones where you can like
drag around stickies and you can like
everybody can kind of collaborate on
like this big whiteboard together
um i found that those can be like
difficult to use but some of the
concepts are useful so like
in my team we've done brainstorming
where we just use google slides
and basically like to prepare for the
brainstorming i do some prep work around
like here are the like
high level like what if questions that
we're trying to get ideas around and
then like
have everybody go off and do their own
brainstorming on separate slides so like
it's really low tech like i'll be like
here's your slide here's your slide
here's your slide and everybody write
down like as many ideas as they can and
it's like the no bad ideas kind of
concept
and then after like 10 or 15 minutes of
everybody doing individually and not
looking at each other's ideas then we
come back together and we try to move
them around to like categorize them so
like we say like okay it looks like
there's actually like five ideas here
and so let's start a new slide for each
of those ideas and everybody can like
move their ideas around so you can see
how some tools where you can like really
like drag and drop stuff would be great
but google slides is a very low tech way
to get the same effect
and then you can start to build on
people's ideas like okay yeah great idea
to do this but what if we also did this
other thing and pulled it together so
i've actually been really excited about
the brainstorming that i can do online
um
i think that's actually maybe one of the
places where
like everybody calling in is kind of
like a great equalizer
um because i know i have colleagues and
things who aren't going to like stand up
and say like let me take over the white
board and tell you all my great ideas
they might sit back in a meeting but
when you give everybody their own slide
people are really happy to like quietly
like fill out their own ideas and put
things there
um it kind of like levels the playing
field
i like that especially the part about
giving everyone the wrong side because
i've noticed in some meetings people who
are a little bit more introverted may
feel a little bit more shy online
meetings at least in my experience so i
like the idea that everyone has at least
a small space and i like the idea of
brainstorming separately and the kind of
coming together collectively i like that
a lot thank you
yeah and then you have the document too
as a record right it's shared with
everybody and you can like
i i don't know i guess i'm trying to
think if there's other platforms that
this works well for i'm just realizing
that like
my previous job where we use like
microsoft i don't know how i can't
remember if you can like actively all
edit the same powerpoint i think so it's
the same idea
um
but yeah
so might
i see mark you suggested um
zoom's whiteboard feature too if you
want to share that
or how that works i don't know why i've
never tried that out before
we should try it out now
it is pretty nifty you can just write on
like the screen so if you need like a
true well hang on
it's been actually a while since i've
used it i can't recall if you can just
fight right directly on the screen or if
there is like a true whiteboard
whiteboard
i think it gives you the option of
either but i've um i've used it
sparingly since i've started my my team
has started coming back into the office
more often
um but i found that that's been helpful
when we were like walking through um
some technical topics that like
needed like a quick just like hand
sketch it's kind of wonky to do it with
a
you know a mouse but it's better than
trying to describe something visual to
someone
cool
i love this topic of brainstorming
too george i i see you put some thoughts
in the chat too if you want to jump in
hey yeah yeah no i was just saying on
top of the um
the walking i know uh
elizabeth's mentioned
billable walks which i think i think is
great and i've worked at consultancy
where where you were definitely
encouraged to
to include thinking time which was which
was great um
but it doesn't it doesn't have to be a
walk it just it's anything where you get
rid of your screens for a minute so i
i'm
like i always have notepads uh in front
of me so i'm like writing most of my
ideas and then i end up
because we do a lot of work on slack
half of my messages are just a photo of
a whiteboard or a photo of a sheet where
i'm like i've written all this stuff
down and i want to put it in a document
but i can't i don't have time or
whatever so i just send it to someone
else and and they end up having to deal
with messy content so i'm probably a
nightmare to work with but i definitely
encourage getting away from screens and
and the physical act of writing is shown
to be really helpful for memory and that
sort of thing is why you write notes
when you're in lectures and that sort of
thing it's not for the content i don't
think as much as it is for you to get
that connection with what you're doing
so yeah
there we go yeah definitely and then
you're focusing on one thing instead of
a million things on your screen at once
yeah yeah yeah and all the pop-ups and
notifications that you get yeah it's why
i
i have a smart watch but i only wear it
for exercise because you just i can't
you can't deal with getting everything
all the time being bugged left right
yeah
yeah
yeah maybe shifting gears a little bit i
see there was a slido uh message that
was what does your tool stack look like
alice
yeah um that's a great question right
now we are pretty
easy
right like we have
a github organization account
we do lots of stuff just like locally
and are in our studio or like python
with vs code
um
everything goes on github when we need a
cloud computer we use google cloud spin
up a vm use docker
store our images on the container
registry it's pretty uh
simple
because there's like three people
working together which is like a huge
luxury
to be able to do things simply like that
um
but yeah you know like
i guess i think it's kind of fun being
at a small company where it's like
if i need to deploy
like a shiny app like i did this the
other day i was like okay i guess i have
to figure out how to do that on google
cloud because there's nobody you know in
the company who's like maintaining an
rstudio connect or something right
i'm like but i can figure it out you
know can google around deploy that
figure out how to get it to work
internally and things like that
i hope that answers the question
awesome thank you
um let me see what other questions were
coming in one was what data science
conferences do you recommend for
industry specific or just in general
oh man that's so hard because i don't
think there are
good ones well i mean it's like i feel
like i belong in
i'm part of like multiple worlds right
because like
i do a lot of things like i'm an
organizer for our ladies philadelphia
and so i feel like i do a lot of like
our general stuff or like like okay i'm
gonna go to our studio conference for
the first time and those sorts of things
which are very much like
general purpose like
our data science type things
but for my job like the conferences i
really go to for that are like
you know acr asco i'm going to bio
they're like
very much around
like clinical trials and that sort of
research and there's often like a
session which is
i think i kind of
talked about this when i was at aacr
they like don't really know what to do
with the data science stuff right like
there'll be a session which is like
genetics and bioinformatics and data
science and
chem informatics
and they all kind of just like get put
together in this like semantic soup of
data intensive work
industry-wise that i will say
one thing is um
embol ebi which is like the european
bioinformatics institute or
okay i hope that's what it stands for
they organize like an industry
consortium which has always been really
fantastic and so they organize different
meetings which are for
people
you know within their industry partner
companies which are a lot of like farm
and biotech
so they're not open to the public but
those sorts of meetings are extremely
valuable because it's a much much
smaller group of people who are working
on some of the same challenges and who
want to collaborate in kind of a
pre-competitive way
awesome
i'll put a shameless plug in for the r
studio conference too
yeah we'll
plug it while we're here
i know um
rwanda you just asked around
certain conferences too
i
okay for a second i got paranoid and i
turned the chat only to hosts and
co-hosts so i can only see the the chat
but um
feel free to unmute yourself too
hi um yes i was wondering if you like
the ismb conferences or the recom
conferences the ones because they're
kind of more about informatics focus but
um that seems pretty relevant for data
science and
oncology yeah i have to be honest i
haven't been in ages
um i haven't been as i recall like ismb
used to like rotate or isd whatever they
call it the conference used to rotate
between it was like in europe and then
be in the u.s
i feel like i probably haven't been
since like 2014.
i've i should go because i think there's
a lot of interesting topics at those
conferences but
um
generally
the kinds of meetings that i've been
going to are much more kind of
disease focused
um
okay but they're good meetings
and i should have explained why i was
being paranoid in the chat yesterday at
a zoom meet up we had some not so great
people who joined and
spammed the chat so
i saw a few people joining with numbers
in their names so i just wanted to make
sure we were good
i'll put the chat back open to
to everyone too
but let's see what other questions were
coming in um
[Music]
someone asked on slido alice have you
experienced a sas to our transition
if so what lessons learned did you find
that would have been useful to know up
front
i have not so i've never worked in like
a more traditional like biostats in
pharma team where they were doing that
um
i have worked with teams
who were
like
this we were like an r team and there's
like a sas team and we want to work
together
and i do think that that's
challenging right to have those kinds of
collaborations across
and so you kind of have to meet people
where they are and like
you know okay let's do some stuff in sas
let's do some stuff in our let's find a
place where we can collaborate together
on the code
but no i have not done that um i've been
fortunate enough to be kind of in a
more
research setting
where it was kind of like use whatever
tools you want we had a lot of freedom
always to do whatever we wanted
basically
uh hi um i'm alex i can maybe chime in a
bit about the sas to our thing yeah
awesome unless someone else had a
question they were first in line to
answer
no that would be great
um yeah so i work at a company where
we're all primarily epidemiologists or
come from some kind of a research
background um and i work with med tech
but basically
we were a team that was primarily sas
users um and then we switched over to r
and it was a real like it was definitely
a challenge um
we made the change because of financial
reasons for pretty much but yeah yeah um
honestly i think people are really happy
when we made the switch but i think what
helped a lot was the r for data science
book
um so i really recommend people read
that
um and i think when a lot of people who
use a lot of people who use sas are
coming from this research background
and
a lot of data science i think is really
structured in this more computer science
framework
um and so
focusing on the tidy verse and going
through art for data science and really
breaking things down into kind of step
by step the research process
really helped my team
get
um get acclimated to r
so um that's what we did we really broke
it down by each step of the analytic
process and we kind of went along with
the r for data science book
and we just looked at okay how do we
import our data how do we
you know get some basic frequencies
um i tried to like when as i was
learning it i tried to compare it like
using the count function the count
function in
um the tidy verse to using proc freak
and sas
so
um there was a lot of like trying to
compare things and there's also a great
online book out there sometimes there's
maybe too many books for r online but
there's one called the epidemiologist
handbook for using r i can share a link
but i thought that was really great for
kind of helping my team
um switch from sas to r because they
really made those comparisons a lot
yeah that'd be great if you share that
link in the chat too
thank you so much
yeah i feel like that's always a
difficult topic maybe around like
how much does a team standardize like
the tools they have them people work
with right i've been interested in this
question in the past right i worked in a
team where it was like
this person uses python for this i use r
for that maybe somebody has a perl
script and we all kind of like did
whatever which has a i mean i feel like
that has some advantages it's nice
people can use whatever tool they want
and feel very much that they can like
pick the right tool for the job
um
when i was at bms we basically
everything was an r it was like we're
just going to use r
it helps a lot for collaboration
so everybody like
alex was just saying like everybody's
learning together it actually is like
building a lot of collaboration and
everybody can then kind of work on the
same code
everybody can share their code everybody
can share their experience so
i also really enjoyed that i'm sure
there were people on the team who were
like
unhappy
having to use r if they really wanted to
use something else
yeah i think that definitely happened on
our team we kept a sas license um just
to keep um you know to make the
transition easier
but i have found that once people
started using r they
actually really enjoyed the flexibility
that came with it um but yeah there
definitely was some pushback
thank you alexander i don't want to
switch topics too quickly if someone
else wanted to jump in on that as well
i can't find the raised hand thing i'm
having to jump in again yeah
um
yeah in terms of so a lot of um
so
a lot of people i deal with it's it's um
it's slightly more archaic than that
it's it's a lot of excel users so i'm
trying to convince them to use data
science tools sort of like showing them
the
options and um so i work in insurers
primarily which i've mentioned a few
times before um
but one of the other things that we're
competing with or that i'm competing
with is someone who goes around as a
sort of r stroke open source data
science specialist is these big um
platforms that come in and have really
expensive licenses and that sort of
things oh it's going to come in it's
going to solve everything this this is
the solution it's sort of like trying to
trying to encourage people not but also
it's that mentality of right we're going
to move everyone from one thing to the
other
and it's pushing people there whereas
one of the things that i try and utilize
in my in my uh to my advantage is
because it's cheap we can get this we
can just set up a server it's really
really cost effective we can make tools
that attract users onto it rather than
things where we're pushing people there
and i think it's so important if you
want to get the buy-in from everyone
it's like look if you want to go and put
everything in excel and deal with all
your links that keep breaking and
everything that keeps collapsing go
ahead but we've also got this solution
over here that a few people are using
now and working and they're getting
loads done and going home at five but so
do do whatever you want and then with
that i find you can attract and get the
conversation flowing a lot more than
coming in with a with a director who
says no no one's allowed to save stuff
in this anymore i yeah i think that's a
yeah it's difficult to do sometimes but
it's it's i think it's a good approach
yeah
yeah thank you
i know alice you're about to jump in and
say something so i didn't want to
switch gears no okay
no i mean it's totally i just i agree
with that right like getting people to
switch tools and things it's like what
do you go with the carrot or the stick
right like
maybe a carrot shaped stick i don't know
like there's that i do agree like it'd
be great to incentivize people
at the end of the day i do think though
depending on like how your organization
is structured and stuff it's extremely
helpful if you're like
senior leadership is also extremely
enthusiastic and can push things
a lot of organizations people get very
frustrated trying to drive things from
the ground up
it's just like you know a lot more
downhill if you have a senior leader who
can get people excited about it as well
yeah definitely
um and on that topic too i know
talking about training people on
onto r or python or coming from excel or
coming from sas i see somebody asked
anonymously if i want to
know how to start doing data science
what resources does everyone have to
share
are there so
you're the many in chat yeah exactly the
flood i feel like we've already got like
the big book of r there's like the
classic like
there's r ones and then there's like
broader like data stuff right and like
maybe yeah for cookbook people are gonna
like put a ton of stuff in the chat
there's gotta be like one master
learn data stuff thing
i i would say maybe though my number one
thing to say would be
find them something that you're excited
about
right so the quote i really like is like
you know the prerequisite for doing
exciting work is being excited about it
right so if you're really excited about
cooking or like
baseball or
cancer research or like marketing
whatever it is like find something like
that that you can do a project with
um
some of the like intro learning stuff
you still need to do it but if you have
a goal in mind like yeah i really want
to analyze my fitbit data or something
um that'll make it so much better to
learn and get into it and then you have
an interesting like case study or
project that you can also use to like
demonstrate that you know what's up
so
i love that
i i actually found twitter to be really
helpful for learning about data science
stuff
i found like
so many resources on there for our and
to be honest it was kind of overwhelming
so really
so looking back like well i think it was
a great place to find things i think
it's also a good idea to like maybe
like think about what you're most
interested in with doing with data
science and just focus on it one one
thing at a time like maybe you really
just wanna do like visualizations and i
think then the tidy maybe you could do
the tidy tuesday visualizations and you
can just focus on that and
i think you'll be surprised how much you
can learn
just from focusing on one little thing
because even those little things have
extra things that come with it so
um so yeah i don't know so i think
there's a lot of ways to find amazing
resources and to learn data science the
hard part is maybe thinking what do you
want to start with first
um
so that's what i would do
[Music]
yeah great point
i i also agree that there's like a
positive like mental reinforcement when
you have like some small successes right
like
there's that like joy of like i made a
plot
like i made a thing and i can like show
it to people i did something and that
really kind of like motivates you to
keep going and i think it helps if it's
something that's not like oh look i
plotted you know like whatever
cars like disc versus horsepower like
who gives [ __ ] sorry like they're that's
not exciting to most people right but if
it's your own data and you can say like
look i plotted my like steps per day or
whatever it's a really exciting like
i don't know like
what's the right endorphin or whatever
that you get from having that that you
can then build on
i love all these uh links in the chat
too
i saw i scrolled up through the chat at
one point libby and i saw you had a
great question
around other skills that help with data
science do you want to jump in
sure i
let me scroll up and look i couldn't
find it yeah
okay um oh yeah so i asked if you have
any
non-data skills or hobbies that you
think make you a better data scientist
and i've been thinking about this a lot
because i feel like the data science
community is really vast and varied
we all have different things we're good
at a lot of us are musicians a lot of us
i know you and i both so like yep
do you have any thoughts on that
oh my gosh i could talk about this for
like an hour okay sorry i could talk
about this for so long it's very
interesting to me
yeah i know i i totally
i totally agree and i think like i've
been somebody who
i've done random projects that are kind
of like intersecting with
data work as well right like
i think even like you know i did an
analysis several years ago like
i live in near philadelphia we have wawa
here so huawei is like a gas station
sandwich company i don't know
it's i don't know if people know it
other places but um
like down the road from my house there
was like they're going to build like a
super wawa which is like a giant like
waddle with gas and so all the neighbors
were like protesting and everything and
i was like okay well i can do some
analysis i can like pull all the
locations for all the wawa in the
country and like analyze like how
different is arawawa from those wahawas
and like bring my skills to the table to
my like angry neighbors to be like
you're right this waba sucks
and like
but you know like it's an example of
like okay i did something weird because
i was interested in the question
but
bigger like i think there's the question
of like what are the soft skills that
make like somebody like a good data
scientist versus like a great data
scientist which is something i've
thought a lot about
um and i think
we can
people ask like okay like what are the
skills you need for data science and i'm
like yeah the table stakes are you have
to come and you have to know some like
programming
maybe something about a database maybe
some statistics and maybe something
about like the business you're in like
so in my case having a strong biologic
knowledge of you know cancer pathways
and things is really important
um but then there's everything else that
makes you like go from good to great so
i tend to think like there's the ability
to communicate and build your network to
influence people right that's super
important
um i think more though it's also about
creativity so how do you address
problems and then how do you find the
right problem that's a huge thing
um i think that's kind of the difference
between being like
somebody who does something versus a
scientist is that you're looking for the
correct question so somebody might come
to you and say like here we're gonna do
this so like
make me
do this analysis you know give me a p
value um but you can come back and say
like actually i think what we really
need is xyz this other thing and i think
that's what differentiates people who
are just kind of good at their job
versus great at their job
yeah but i could talk about it forever
because how you develop those skills i
think are sometimes
not from your day job they're from like
the other things that you go out and
develop about yourself
you might not actually cultivate those
skills in your nine to five
i agree it's amazing
thanks alice
and i definitely need to go to owaba
apparently there's a lot of love oh yeah
i
i also like so i gave like a lightning
talk about like this wawa and it was
funny because everybody was like when i
started they were like yeah voila it's
gonna be this like pro wawa talk and i
was like oh
i'm actually very anti wawa
i was like this is the wrong crowd for
this i should have like prefaced like
i'm gonna be saying that i don't want
the wawa
um i see there was an anonymous question
it just came in um i understand
averaging for missing values but where
do you stop on deleting data with a lot
of nas
i mean i think that that's going to
depend on your field right like um
i'll say
in the in the field that i'm in like
yeah
i work right now with like
observational data so it's a real world
data from patients like if you're an
oncology patient and you go to your um
oncologist
they'll be collecting all sorts of
information about your family history
your current diagnosis your treatment
your
um how you're doing on that treatment
and then
companies can curate that information
for research purposes right so they're
trying to understand everything they can
about real cancer patients
today in the real world versus clinical
trials which are kind of a different
situation but in that data you have a
huge issue with missing this right
because unlike in a clinical trial where
we're going to fill out we require
all this information you're not going to
necessarily get all that information
from a patient's medical record
especially if you're curating
unstructured data from pathology reports
and things like that um but in that case
you have to be extremely careful because
the data is not usually missing at
random
right uh so the data is missing because
maybe
this practice had this type of emr and
so that data was available and this
practice had this other type but those
are from two different completely
different things right um different
regions different types of clinical
practice all those things so
um
i don't know in at least in the field
that i've worked in with like medical
data or biological data
uh you never really get rid of it
never throw away the data you have to
justify it especially if you're in like
a regulated environment like if you're
working on like a clinical study
um it has to be very well documented uh
why you would throw out a data point
you know thank you
read the theranose book or whatever
thinking about like you should not throw
my data points
for sure i see um robert had asked the
question in the chat towards the
beginning of the talk which i missed um
he said interested in hearing how the
nature of the work is different at
the
bigger companies you talked about like j
j bristol myers versus a smaller life
science company
yeah i think we have a different focus
maybe i can speak to my own like
personal experience
i think one thing at a big level is that
at a big company
you have incredible access to expertise
so if you're at a big pharma company you
have
med chem people who have been doing that
for 20 years and they're incredible
you have commercial people who know all
about how to
get drugs on the market you have people
in manufacturing you know everything
about that you have lawyers so
that expertise is all there internally
and you can email them you can find them
you know if you're brave enough you can
get it
when you work at a small company
that expertise all exists just not
within your company
and so you have to go out and you have
to get it and i feel like that's like
one of the key
differences is that like
yeah you have to do it differently that
way i think
it's still all there though right it's
not like i have to become all of a
sudden an expert i'm not going to become
you know a medicinal chemist
but i can
get a contract with the medicinal
chemist to consult with me
that's maybe one one big difference the
other thing would be the focus right we
just have a slightly um
smaller focus and also
uh the need to kind of like pivot from
project to project as priorities dictate
is probably a little bit smaller
thank you
um i see jan um
your name wrong you had a follow-up
question from the question before you
want to jump
in oh yeah i'm sorry um yeah just jen
i tried we can hear you ask and then
oh sorry uh yeah so um
alex you just to
talk about how you treat the data with
the record anytime that you changes
especially for those missing data i just
uh wonder um what was your
during the project that you are
what was your
the the frequency of for changing your
missing data
uh replaced by the uh mean
exactly do you often do that or you you
totally not doing it by the you know
which cases how do you yeah
yeah it's
that's a great question
i think it's always going to depend on
your your use case here what you do
right like i i've been involved in
projects before where there are
different methods to impute missing data
like
and a couple good r packages to do this
as well but i don't want to say the
names off the top of my head in case i
get them wrong um
but yeah like sometimes you do need to
impute missing data um yeah exactly mice
is probably one of them right um but it
depends on what you're doing right and
whether you want to impute data or not
um
it depends on your on your use case
sure
okay and then you don't have a
you know like estimated how often you do
that or occasionally no okay no no idea
sorry so this is not like a habit you
you should establish it right
yeah i mean i but i think it's a
challenge of working with like i said
like
it really is sometimes though
you can think about different things
when you're working with data right like
yeah the answer is always it depends um
but one thing to keep in mind is
sometimes we tend to think like
the data comes from somewhere and
now we have the data and we have to deal
with it and we can engineer this crazy
complicated solution around the data or
whatever but the data didn't come from a
fairy that came and said like data like
the data came from a machine or person
or a study or something like that and
like
that's often hard that we just don't
even think about that it's like okay the
data came and now we have the data well
the data didn't come from magic like you
could go and talk and see if you can get
some of that data right so like if it's
a clinical study or something like
there's a site who put in that data and
you can go and talk to them and try to
get different data or rerun a plate or
something if there's
you know a qc problem or something like
that and i think that's like something
that i personally forget all the time
because i'm just so used to like
i have to over engineer a solution to my
data versus trying to get better data
i see i like all these comments in the
chat too
yeah there's some great comments in the
chat about life
and then you don't
really just drop it right you just keep
it uh whatever
depends on i i'm going to go back to it
depends
it depends on your question right and if
you think that like
you're really
biasing your population a lot by
removing and only looking at the
patients that have that data or don't
have that data that's the question
really right so certainly yeah like
sometimes you only look at a subset like
that's that's generally how biomarker
studies work right if you have a large
clinical study
you're not going to have biomarker data
on all the patients and that's because
there wasn't a sample available
the sample didn't generate useful data
there's a lot of failure rates when
you're working with biological samples
so you end up evaluating like a
biomarker population versus the whole
population but the key is always to
demonstrate or to evaluate how similar
that population is to your larger sample
which again is not really representative
of all patients but that's the idea
um and it's really important because
sometimes you can have
a biomarker population that is skewed
and somehow biased and then it would not
reflect your larger population
thank you so much
thanks for the question too um i see um
slido there's a bunch of questions
coming in too and i love this one
um that just came in what leadership
qualities have made the biggest mark on
you
positive and or negative
leadership qualities
yes what leadership qualities have made
the biggest mark on you
i mean
i tend to think like
i can think of good leaders that i've
had in the past and what made a good
leader um
and so like i apologize i'd probably
sworn already like three times on this
so let me try to like think of a way to
say it without swearing like
the number one thing is like don't be a
jerk right like there are plenty of good
leaders who are complete a-holes and
there are plenty of like people who are
successful who aren't so there's got to
be a choice there and so i think like
there are great leaders who really care
about the people that they work with
and
um
try to do right by people right like i
think we've all had managers where in
the past like they've made your life
miserable but i i fundamentally don't
believe that people wake up in the
morning and are like i'm gonna come to
work and do a crappy job and i'm gonna
make everybody unhappy like it's all
these other circumstances that make
somebody be toxic in a work environment
but like yeah so leadership it's like
number one don't be a jerk i think the
other thing is really communication i'm
a huge
advocate of people communicating up and
down right so like if you're a manager
you have to communicate a lot with your
reports but you also need to communicate
a lot with your management and then your
peers
um and especially to advocate for your
team so i think like the leaders that i
really respect are the people who are
all constantly advocating for their team
right so like i go to a lot of like
retirement conferences and things
and the people who are constantly giving
credit for the people who did the work
those are the kind of i'm like wow
they're great i like them great great
job when somebody doesn't have any
acknowledgements or anything and there's
lies i'm like
what what what's going on like nobody
wants to work for them right um so
yeah like people who are generous
who communicate a lot those are kind of
the leadership qualities that i tend to
hone in on like am i doing a good enough
job communicating
um
i think the third thing is seeing the
big picture so that's probably kind of
like some overlap there with the other
two
that like sometimes people get promoted
into leadership positions because
they're really good at their
technical work
um
but i think
being able to see a bigger picture of
how your work fits into that larger
picture
is very very important
um
yeah and you don't have to be like
constantly giving ted talks and things
about like your vision and like
how you can see everything about the
future but
being able to help connect what
everybody's doing to
the mission of the company or to some
sort of like bigger impact is really
important because it's just very
demotivating if you're working on
something you can't see how it relates
to
um
something
bigger than your individual work
that's such a good point i always seem
to notice that too in presentations when
people are highlighting
others on their team
yeah i just feel like it's such an easy
win like why not be more generous yeah
definitely i see there's quite a few
packages that are being shared in chat
too so i i'm gonna ask this question now
someone asked what do you have a
favorite r package
favorite r package ever
i know it's a hard question
i feel like now i should after we were
talking about that i should be like
actually i really like internal art
packages that people have developed at
companies i've worked for right so
they're not publicly available but
people in my team at bms developed car
packages that were used in by the
department which were great right
because it's like here i've identified a
need an ability to help co-workers
and so i guess
what would be a publicly available r
package that would be my favorite um
i like all my internal our packages but
i don't know that's a really hard one i
i mean probably if i like did an
analysis of what i actually use it's
deep flyer and ggplot2 right like
everybody like
so i guess that
awesome
thank you
um i'm going to go over to some other
questions from slido but if there are
questions that you all want to ask feel
free to raise your hand here on on zoom
2.
um i see
isabella just sent me a
direct message with a question so i'll
ask it um
but what do you find to be the most
effective way to communicate your data
insights to stakeholders
especially stakeholders you might not
engage with as much
so this is where i could use help on
remote work right um
because i do think that sometimes the
most effective communications i've had
i've been in person
and i don't have that anymore really
usually we don't do a lot of in-person
stuff
uh so that's where i would love to hear
how other people are doing things
because i think there are different
schools of thought like sometimes it's
like okay you need something interactive
so somebody could like explore and then
make their own
interpretations or whatever i tend to
not think that i'm more of a fan of like
the executive summary
where i'm like here's exactly what i
mean like no interpretation it's like
here's the result because i've seen a
lot of people come up with slides or
presentations or something where it's
like here's a bunch of things i did i
did this here's a plot i did this here's
a table i did this here's a table and i
prefer if somebody comes to the table or
comes to the meeting or whatever and
says
here's actually what i think you should
take away from it like yes here's all
the receipts i have the plots i have the
methods i have all that stuff but i'm
trying to convince you that this
actually means this right like i'm
trying to convince you that we found
this and it's important or we actually
we did all this work and we need to stop
doing this because
it's not working or
we our hypothesis was wrong or something
like that so maybe my biggest
communication tip would be
have a lot of like tldr's like executive
summary like this is the number one
thing you should take away from what i'm
telling you and then here's a ton of
backup so if you want to go through and
see like the nitty-gritty detail if you
want to see my code if you want to see
everything it's there but the number one
thing is like this is what i want you to
i'm trying to persuade you of this point
i love that i was just writing that time
stamp down to remember to go back to
that
um brittany on that topic i see you just
put a great comment into the chat too if
you want to if you'd want to expand on
that
yeah i think um
i tend to mentor a lot of analysts more
junior animals at my company and one
thing that i noticed is you can tell
that someone's growing in their career
when they go from
this is the road i took and then finally
telling you like
why you should care about all the stuff
i just told you before versus like lead
with the headline and start with what
people care about and sometimes the
people that you're working with will
want to know how you got there and
sometimes they won't so then you just
give yourself in them a whole lot of
headache by doing it that way
totally and i i think that people also
like
i have to say like i make this mistake
myself all the time right like i'll talk
to somebody and i'll think whoa i messed
that up i should have been way more like
short like i didn't need all that detail
or whatever so i think it is something
that like no matter if it's like your
first day or you're like you know
10 000 say like we all kind of use
reminders on that actually because it's
sometimes we default to like i'm just
going to show you what i did versus like
why you should care
i love this discussion if other people
have tips or anything you want to add as
well
this is really helpful for me too i
feel like sometimes i try to fit way too
much into those 30-minute meetings that
you have
yeah i think sometimes i go too far too
right like i've had a couple recently
where like
i kind of assumed i was like they're not
going to want to see the the data and
then my co-workers are like yes yes they
want to see the data and then like i
sent them the data and they came back
with like they actually went through
everything i was like oh
okay like i shouldn't assume that like
if somebody is an executive they want
only two sentences they might actually
want to see more
yeah
awesome um so one other question was
i imagine this is not an issue at a
startup however
in past workplaces
have you had any challenges with
colleagues misperceiving your
inquisitiveness
uh
no i think that's interesting though um
i'm
i'm generally a very curious person i
have a lot of interest um
but
i think you kind of have to know when
there's like a time and a place for
being like
talking a lot versus like not talking
um
and that's a great place to ask your
like colleagues and stuff for
feedback where i like to be like okay
like
is it just me or you know was i the only
one talking in that meeting like or or
things like that no i can't think of a
time to be honest
where
it was neces it was necessarily like
misinterpreted i think i've been very
fortunate to work in research settings
where
um curiosity is is rewarded and people
are also
very
um accepting of you asking
questions
right like i'm i'm not afraid to if i
don't know something i'll ask
um and i think that's always been
i i actually respect that a lot in
people so it's maybe back to like a
leadership question right
it's people who know what they know and
kind of like are comfortable with what
they don't know
so
you know if you don't know something in
a meeting
i'm happy to ask about it even if it's
something that's really basic for
somebody else like if i don't know it
that's fine
um and i really respect that in in
leaders that i've seen who will say like
you know what i have no idea what
precision means so like you're gonna
have to explain it to me
yeah
that's a great point
i know
an hour is going by very quickly um
but i know when we when we first
met actually i think it was on our lady
slack and then a discussion we talked a
little bit about like a role that you're
hiring for and your thoughts around
hiring i just was curious are you still
hiring oh yeah
i am and i think that is also another
difference between like a big company
and a small company is that um at a big
company you kind of have
a lot of baggage maybe that like people
know about the company so that can be a
huge incentive because they're like oh
great look at this like great company
it's a big company i want to work there
and so you get a lot of like the
work done for you of explaining the
company
um so when i've been hiring for my new
job
uh at least until recently we didn't
have a website
we had three employees
and so i had to work a lot within my
network to be like okay let me explain
to you please just give me an opening
and then now like since you know nothing
about the company i'm gonna have to
explain it to you a lot more than i had
to in the past when it was like have you
heard of johnson and johnson like
people kind of know it and they're not
as um
there's less work there to do that but i
would actually love i don't know if we
have time yet for people to talk about
if they've had any particularly like
positive or negative remote hiring
experiences
because that's been something i've been
kind of experimenting with is
how do i make an interview a good
experience for a candidate because at
the end of the day i'm trying to sell
them on like come work with us like i
want you to be excited about coming
to this job um so i don't want the
interview to be like too long but i also
don't want to be too short because then
they're not going to know enough about
the job to like come and do it so i
would love to hear if people have tips
or like
particularly good or even like
particular nightmare like i would love
to hear like a hiring nightmare
situation so that i can never do that
um
yeah
because hiring remote is is definitely
um
[Music]
it creates new challenges
yeah
yeah um
just in terms of the nightmare situation
um
this was years ago about 10 years ago
but we hired someone
this was before i got into the way i'm
using r today and python and whatnot but
we had we were giving excel technical
interviews
and we were telling all the candidates
in advance we're going to be doing excel
technical interviews and this one
individual like blew it out of the park
um
it turns out that
they must have like
really really studied for
the basics that we were looking for
um
since then
i have had way more success not giving
that kind of technical interview and
literally the technical interview is
more of a discussion
i would much rather prefer hiring
someone if i ask them like hey you know
how to develop shiny apps i'd much
rather someone tell me i've never
developed a shiny app in my life but
i use our markdown every day or you know
like that tells me a lot about their
ability to actually jump in and learn
something new and like just their
transparency so i feel like the types of
technical interviews i've had a lot of
success with the last few years has been
more like
almost more like a discussion technical
interview where i'm not even asking them
to whiteboard anything or it's just
talking
yeah
no i love that and that's what i'm
trying to get at like if you wanna if
you do you have any good questions that
you ask in those like technical
interview discussions or something i
would love to hear them
um
because that's what i'm kind of working
on i i have this like evolving list of
like interview questions and and how we
ask them to try to get at some of these
things right because in some ways i'm
much more interested in the process
right like how
how do people approach a problem and
solve challenges that they encounter
versus the specific
project they worked on because you know
they're not going to work on that
project ever again with me it's going to
be a new project so they're going to
have to learn something anyway for sure
yeah i i'm also i've had like the last
few roles i've placed have been
exclusively from our related
things whether it's
meetups or r hackathons or it's people
i've met to the point where i'm starting
to feel like i need to make more of an
effort to get into like a python related
hackathon or a python conference or
something um you know where i might be
like over indexing on our folks um
but
seeing these people at hackathons and
the way they just problem solve
you know in like a
a day or four hours of seeing how
someone thinks you really get a lot of
insight about these individuals
i don't know just some tips that have
worked for me
that's awesome
thank you
brittany i see you have your hand raised
too you want to jump in
yeah my company actually does um we do
do a technical interview and it's we
give candidates a data set um while
they're sort of on site whether that's
them actually being on site or just
being in like a teams meeting and then
we give them maybe like an hour hour and
a half to actually just see what sorts
of insights you find with a few very
specifically directed questions
and what we're often looking for is not
someone to have perfect answers to those
questions um kind of like what you said
it's really about understanding how did
you look at the data set what other
information would you want what do you
wish you had been like had more time to
do
um so you really get to see like javier
said how people are thinking how they
work through something and it's okay if
they don't have like a perfectly
polished presentation after like 45
minutes or so
that's that's great brittany um
i was just trying to read through some
of the other comments in the chat too
um
george did i see your hand was raised
earlier
yeah briefly okay
so i had a i guess it was it was it was
part of a interview that covered both
technical and software this was pretty
pandemic and that was on site and but it
was r based questions and
i it went horrifically i but they gave
me the job in the end but
um
the
the bit which was absolutely horrible
and i like
still get cold sweats thinking about it
like i i just sort of froze and things
it became like a pub quiz on our stuff
and that is like the categorically my my
worst nightmare of it was like
what packages are in the tidy verse like
just and at the time i didn't use tidy
burst i was base uh and so i ended up
going on site and getting a job and
learning televised really well and
loving it um but so this was like four
or five years ago i can't remember 2018
and yeah it was just yeah that that sort
of like what package would you use to do
this what function would you use that
i'm like i have no idea i can't answer
this question so that was hard
i feel like one that sticks in my head
from an interview i did was they were
like please describe in detail the
differences between python 3 and python
2.
right like is that an answer
uh there's no there's back there's
non-backward compatible changes
maybe
f printing i feel like
i could think of f printing that
they i mean
i was i kind of said like honestly i'm
not gonna answer that question
have you ever answered anything with
this is something i would google because
i feel like that's
a valid answer sometimes it's like
i don't know this but i know where to
find it so like i feel really confident
in my ability to google this i feel like
it's a valid response for me
yeah it's a skill
yeah honestly if i asked somebody a
question and they said that they were
like you know what this is something
that i know i know where i could find
the answer to that i would be like
perfect answer
like that's a perfect answer to me like
not knowing but knowing where to find
the information great
absolutely
ruvonda i see you have your hand raised
too
yes i was just going to say that i liked
britney's
idea on a technical interview i was just
personally
similar to alice and some others i
didn't get getting questions that you
could just go on
google or
find something like that very technical
and i also because of my field i went um
probably like five or six years ago i
went on three different interviews and
they had a technical part on algorithms
and every single one of them the answer
was dynamic programming so they must
have gone somewhere
and decided that that was the algorithm
to ask about and i find that a little
bit ridiculous because it wasn't really
relevant to what they were working on
and i got to the point where i found
that was a little bit off-putting so
whenever i interview people i try to
make it more like britney does which is
more of a conversation around the data
and what we might actually be doing
because you can google things you can
learn things it's more about problem
solving
yeah so that is i have been doing that a
little bit so i have a like i have like
an optional take home which is that it's
like here's a data set take an hour and
tell me something use whatever tools you
want use excel use r use python use
you know an abacus and just the key
thing i want to see is i want to see
some sort of like written output of like
what you did and what you would do if
you had more time um so
i'm still kind of on the fence though
because i know that a lot of people are
like so anti having like any kind of
technical component that i'm still
trying to feel out like okay
net
is it better to have it or better not to
have it you know like is it really
helping us make the best hiring
decisions
but i do love that format like i think
what you describe is awesome
mark says style points if they use an
abacus though
right yeah like honestly right if
somebody came with like some crazy
creative thing where they were like
you know i did something
i don't know maybe it would be a pro
i know we're a little bit over the top
of the hour so i just want to make sure
there weren't questions that
i missed either on
and yeah libby an hour is never enough
but questions i missed on slido or
anything in the chat feel free to
raise your hand
and alice while people are thinking of
last questions or if they had any what's
the best way for people to stay in touch
with you
oh yeah um
i think probably linkedin um i'm on
linkedin i'm also on twitter my handle
is science alice
um so you can follow me on twitter for
the five times a year i tweet something
um yeah but like linkedin or twitter are
great um yeah and i would love to hear
people like honestly i would love to
hear people's interview ideas especially
for like remote hiring great things that
they're doing that they think have
worked really well or places that
they're finding
are really great for hiring would love
it if you reach out to me on that sort
of thing
i was just thinking back to one of the
data science hangouts i think the last
one of last
year we were talking
about hiring in great deal and i was
just i'm bad at multitasking but i was
trying to find it at the same time
yeah
let me just
grab it real quick unless tyler hannah
you can
share the one from ryan garnett
okay it might start playing on youtube
when i click on this so apologies
okay i got it i always hate when the
youtube videos start with my own voice
and i have to listen to my voice there
um but i just shared that i think it
would be helpful for everyone too um but
thank you so much alice this was awesome
yeah thank you i mean
i had a lot of fun so
really appreciate you sharing your
experience with us and thank you for all
the great questions too
i'll see everybody next week hopefully
um
we will be joined by travis gerk
um
from the prostate clinical
research trials
awesome thanks everyone have a great
rest of today
you